[موسيقى]
سئل شيخ كيف يشكل المسلمون مصدر خوف
للعالم في زمن ضعفهم وتقهقورهم وضياع
وحدتهم وهم بفارق طوق عين على حربين
مدمرتين بمسوغات كاذبه بين البوشين الاول
والثاني دفعوا نحو مليونير ضحيه بالسلاح
الاشقر وتشرد الملايين وعندما غضب
فلاديمير بوتين جهزوا مليون تابوت والاف
قوارب الموت واللجوء في ناحيه اخرى اذا
احتدمت انتخابات المحتلين سفكت دماء
المرابطين قرابين لصناديق اقتراعهم واذا
اضطرت فرنسا لملء خزائنها جاع اطفال
افريقيا واندلعت حروبها فاجاب الشيخ
الحكيم
كبارهم يدركون باننا لسنا دمويين فعندما
كانت لدينا اسنان قاطعه جدا لم ناكل احدا
لكنهم بعد ان اقتنعوا اسناننا بايديهم
يروجون باننا نريد ان ناكلهم كي يضمنوا
عدم نبات اسناننا التي يمكن ان استعدناها
ان نقاوم بها افتراسنا الى العناوين
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يدنسون الاقصى
ويدهسون المعتكفين
دونالد ترامب اول رئيس امريكي يساق الى
المحاكم بتهم جنائيه
الجيش العراقي يعتقل مسلحين يحملون بطاقات
الحشد الشعبي واعلام داعش ومتفجرات
موسكو تتهم واشنطن وبطريركيه القسطنطينيه
باقحام الدين في حرب اوكرانيا
رئيس حزب فرنسي يصف ايمانويل ماكرون
بالكلب المطيع للامريكيين
وكاله ايطاليه تؤكد ومعارضون تضع نعوى
وسعيد ينفي هل اصيب رئيس تونس بنوبه قلبيه
اعتراض متطرف يميدي لبناني على تكريم وزير
الثقافه شيرين ابو عاقله
[موسيقى]
تلك كانت مشاهد خاطفه من اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الوحشي للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
حيث عاثوا تقريبا وتحطيما وضربا عنيفا
للمصلين
في ليالي رمضان المباركه لفهم العقليه
الاسرائيليه نستمع الى تصريح سابق لرئيس
حكومه ووزير دفاع سابق هو يهود براك الذي
يصنف اليوم بانه احدى حمامات السلام في
اسرائيل
يفاخر براك بقتله 300 فلسطيني في ثلاث
دقائق ونصف وزير جيش الاحتلال الاسبق هود
برك يعترف امام الكاميرات انه قتل اكثر من
300 فلسطيني في ثلاث دقائق ونصف فقط ربما
يؤهل هذا الرقم باراك لدخول موسوعه جينيس
في الاجرام اهوت براك هذا يستجير الان من
وزير الامن القومي ايتامار بن جبير ويعتبر
تعيينه مسؤولا عن قوات الحرس الوطني خطوه
جنونيه من نتنياهو لانه بن جبير ارهابي
ايضا على المجتمع اليهودي يعني مش بس على
الفلسطينيين على اليهود كمان علينا ولا
عليهم
الذي وصل به الغرور الى تحدي امريكا
يتهمه قاده شرطه الاحتلال بالتمهيد
الانقلاب والاستيلاء على السلطه خصوصا بعد
شرعنه نتنياهو ميليشياته الثوريه
الحرس الوطني اخر قرارات حكومه نتنياهو
المثيره للجدل تحت ضغط من جناحها اليمني
المتطرف وعلى راسه وزير الامن القومي
اتمار قاده في الشرطه الاسرائيليه حذروا
من استغلال بنجفير الحرس الوطني ليصبح
ميليشيات تابعه له لا للجيش او الشرطه ومن
استخدامه لتنفيذ انقلاب على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه فيما بعد
تفتقد الشاشات لكثير من الدعاه عبر
الاعلام في رمضان حول العالم الاسلامي
بداع الوفاه او المرض او الاعتقاد
فخاري وجد الساحه قاحله فجرب حظه بالعظات
الرمضانيه نصيحه من القران ليوم الجمعه
الا المفترين وظالمين ويحق الله الحق
بكلماته ولو كره المجرم
الا الحاقدين ام حسب الذين في قلوبهم مرض
ان لن يخرج الله ادغامهم والى الباغضين
اتقوا الله
واسلوا ونصيحه من القران الكريم لفخاي في
سوره البقره اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
ان الله لا يحب المعتدين صدق الله العظيم
وبالتاكيد يا فخاي ان الله لا يحب ايضا
الناطقين باسم المعتدين ولا الكاذبين وزير
اسرائيلي سابق يقول مشكله الفلسطينيين هي
انهم صدقوا الاسرائيليين
الامارات في اسرائيل محمد خازه الذي اشتهر
بطلب البركه الدينيه من اكثر حاخامات
اسرائيل تطرفا شالوم كوهين الذي يعتبر ان
العرب مجرد افاعي وصراصير اقام مادبه
افطار رمضاني في منزله بتل ابيب شارك فيه
عدد من المسؤولين في الحكومه والبرلمان
الاسرائيليين حضرها ايضا عضو الكنيسه
ورئيس الحركه الاسلاميه
المولوده في رحم الاخوان المسلمين منصور
عباس الذي اشاد بالاهتمام الاماراتي بعرب
اسرائيل
رمضان ازدمان اوف بيس
كما يمثل اي متهم بجنايه قتل او سرقه او
اغتصاب في امريكا مثل رئيس الولايات
المتحده السابق دونالد ترامب بسنواته الست
والسبعين
وبملياراته الثلاث من الدولارات امام
محكمه من هاتن الجنائيه في نيويورك ثم
اخلي سبيله بدون شروط قد تبدا محاكمته
العام المقبل وسقف العقوبه اربع سنوات سجن
لو قدر له تنفيذها سيدشن عقده التاسع خلف
القطبه
نفى جميع التهم وبينها متهمته به ممثله
افلام اباحيه حول دفعه اموالا لها بلغت
130 الف دولار واكثر من ذلك لامراه اخرى
قبيلا انتخابات رئاسه الفين 2016 كي
تتكتما على امر علاقه جنسيه اقامها معهما
سره التحقيقات مهينه لامريكا وليس له
شخصيا يقول ترامب امام انصاره وهي دبرت
بليل لابعاد شبح ترامب الذي يطارد احلام
الديمقراطي جو بايدن بولايه رئاسيه ثانيه
في بيت الزهايمر الابيض يعلق جمهوريون من
انصار ترامب وطلعت كل على بعضها شغله
نسوان في قاضي مرته بتكره ترامب عندها بنت
بتشتغل عن خصومه وبتحبها كما لهاريس
فركبوا لها التهمه ولك ايه ما تفكروا
امريكا شغله يعني بيقول ترامب
لم اتخيل ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث في
امريكا الجريمه الوحيده التي ارتكبتها هي
الدفاع الى خوف عن امتنا في وجه اولئك
الذين يسعون لتدميرنا لدي قاض يكره ترامب
زوجته وكل عائلته تكره ترامب ولديه
وتتلقى الاموال من حمله بايدن توجيه 34
تهمه جنائيه للمرشحه الرئاسي البالغ من
العمر 76 عاما ومحاكمته في شهر يناير من
عام 2024 فرصه
ذهبيه بالنسبه للديمقراطيين لمنع عدوهم
اللدود من العوده مجددا الى البيت الابيض
الخلاصه في امريكا الخيانه الزوجيه مبدوعه
وممنوعه الرشوه لشراء الصمت وممنوع الكذب
حتى لو كان الكذب من السياسيين
سيطاطئ راسه مهما على تحت اقواس المحاكم
في بلاد الفقوس والحظ المنحوس مسموح
اغتصاب الشعب باكمله والرشوه يدفعها
الفقراء عاده ليرضى عنهم الاثرياء
والمحاكم لا تحاكم الحاكم فهي اعدت
للناقضين الفاهمين
وسارقين الارغفه الجائعين
[موسيقى]
القت قوه من الجيش العراقي في محافظه
ديالى القبض على مسلحين يحملون بطاقات
انتساب للحشد الشعبي واعلى مداعش ومتفجرات
الناسفه واجهزه اتصال وقد بوشرت التحقيقات
لتحديد حقيقه هوياتهم
كتاب تحويل قياده عجله بالحشد الشعبي صعدت
على جزء اللي على اساس اول كرتونه
لقيتها
[موسيقى]
يا ولد
اعتقلت القوات الحكوميه الخاصه بضبط الامن
في محافظه ديالى شبكه مسلحه تتالف من
ثلاثه افراد يحملون اسلحه واعلاما داعشيه
جنوب المحافظه واكدت المصادر الحدث ان
الاشخاص يحملون هويات امنيه تابعه للحشد
الشعبي وهم رهن التحقيق مع قياده شرطه
ديالا مضيفا ان التحقيقات هي من ستكشف
هويه افراد الشبكه تجمع بين الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر مبادئ تشكل هويه مشتركه من
ابرزها لا يجوز ان ينحازا الى اي طرف او
يتخلاه في خلافات سياسيه وغيرها
في الهلال الاحمر الاماراتي واثناء توزيعه
المساعدات في سوريا يوصي الفقراء
بالالتفاف حول قياده النظام السوري الطيبه
والمباركه كما وصفها اذا ارادوا ان يجدوا
ما يسرهم والجسور الجويه تتوالى وصيه لكم
مني التف حول قيادتكم الرشيده فهي قياده
خير مباركه
وسوف تجدون ما يسركم باذن الله
موسكو تتهم واشنطن وبطريركيه القسطنطينيه
الارثوذكسيه باقحام الدين في حرب اوكرانيا
مع ان بطريرك موسكو يحرص بنفسه ايضا على
مباركه غرف قياده المعارك وعلى تبخير
الطائرات المقاتله قبيله توجهها الى
عمليات القتل والتدمير
موسكو ان تصرفات القياده الاوكرانيه
العدائيه ضد الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
ما كانت لتكون لولا تغذيتها ودعمها من
الغرب البعني باطفاء الطابع الديني على
الازمه الاوكرانيه يسعى النازيون جدد
الاوكران حاليا للاستيلاء على ثاني اكبر
دير وهو
وتجهي هذه العمليات التعسفيه بدعم من
واشنطن وبطرياتيه القسطنطينيه زعيم حركه
الوطنيون في فرنسا فلوريام فيليبو يعتبر
ان فرنسا الان ليست في وضع يسمح لها
باعطاء الدروس للعالم ويقول في ماكرونستان
يتعرض المتظاهرون والصحفيون للضرب المبرح
ونحن نعطي دروسا لروسيا
ولشركاء روسيا ماكرون الذي يعيش ازمه في
كل مكان بالعالم يتهم روسيا بجرائم حرب
واوكرانيا تعتبر روسيا الدوريه لمجلس
الامن عارا على الامن
الدوليا تصف تولي روسيا رئاسه مجلس الامن
الدولي بالعار ليس مجرد عار انها ضربه
رمزيه اخرى لنظام العلاقات الدوليه
القائمه على القواعد البيت الابيض اعتبر
من جهته على لسان المتحدثه ان روسيا لسوء
الحظ عضوا دائما في مجلس الامن ولا يوجد
مسار قانوني دولي عملي لتغيير هذا الواقع
الرئيس الفرنسي اتهم الجمعه روسيا بانها
سمحت بل شجعت قواتها على ارتكاب جرائم حرب
في اوكرانيا
يقول ايضا ان واشنطن اذلت الرئيس الفرنسي
في انتقادها لقمع المتظاهرين في المدن
الفرنسيه
احتجاجا على الخطط الاجتماعيه لمانيول
ماكرون وحكومته وكتب فيليبو يمكن لماكرون
ان يلعب دور الكلب المطيع للامريكيين
بتعبيره لكنهم اهانوه فالكلب لا تتم
الاشاده به بل يوبخ وكان البيت الابيض قد
اعلن انه يدعم حق التظاهر في كل مكان
بالعالم بما في ذلك فرنسا صحيح ان في
فرنسا يستطيع الفرنسي ان يصف ماكرون
بالكلب لكن في كثير من الدول العربيه ايضا
يستطيع المواطن ان يصف ماكرون بالكلب
بهيج
[موسيقى]
حبه التمر وشربه الماء باتت ترعب قيم
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه بلا زغره الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم يمنع توقيف المباريات
لدقيقتين عند الغروب ليكسر الصائبون من
اللاعبين صيامهم بحبه تمر مش بصدر منسف
القرار جاء مخالفا لتوجهات الاتحاد
البريطاني والاتحادات الاوروبيه اجمالا
والتي طلبت تسهيل افطار الصائمين الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم على عكس الاتحادات
الاوروبيه الاخرى اقدم على تصرف مفاجئ ضد
لاعبين المسلمين يامر فيه حكام الدوري
الفرنسي ودرجات الادنى بعدم ايقاف
المباريات التي يوجد بها لاعبون مسلمون
للسماح لهم بالافطار خلال شهر رمضان تحول
مسيره دينيه هندوسيه مقدسه في ولايه بهار
بالهند الى حفله اعتداءات وحشيه ورجب
واحراق لمنازل المسلمين
وممتلكاتهم وقد افيد عن وقوف الشرطه على
الحياد وهذا ما يفسر بالبوابه والرضا كما
احرقت الجماعات الهندوسيه الارهابيه مدرسه
العزيزيه الاسلاميه العريقه بولايه نلندا
واتت النيران على المدرسه والمسجد والاف
المصاحف والكتب والمخطوطات النادره سئم
هؤلاء المساكين المغلوب على امرهم من
الاستغاثه بحكومات الدول الاسلاميه التي
لا تريد او لا تستطيع على ما يبدو ان تنطق
بكلمه لوقف حملات ابادتهم وتهجيرهم
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد دائم الظهور على
الشاشات كما تعلمون اثار غيابه لنحو عشره
ايام شائعات عن وضعه الصحي رفض وزير الصحه
علي مرابط الاجابه على سؤال حوله
هل هناك
ما صمت عنه وزير الصحه التونسي كشفته
وكاله نوفا الايطاليه وعلى ذمتها بان سعيد
اصيب بنوبه قلبيه شفاه الله وقد عولج منها
بتدخل جراحي في المستشفى فصل المقال القاه
قيس بعد القير والقال فظهر وعليه اثار
مشقات ثقال انا هنا لم اهن لم اسقم ولم
اسام قال وكل من نعاني حيا واحالني الى
القدر ساحيله الى القضاء والسجن خير ما
قال
وشهور سد الشهور
لا يثيرون الا الازدراع والاحتقار حتى
اليوم
الصباح قالوا وفاه
شهاده وفاه يخرج شهادات وفد في المتفرقات
ايضا دخل السجن طبالا فخرج منه مايسترو
مرتضى منصور رئيس نادي الزمالك يحوط
المساجين من شر الحسد لانه ما شفش في
امريكا ولا في انجلترا ولا في المانيا
سجون فخمه زي اللي عندنا فهل طاف على سجون
اوروبا يغزى العين وباي تهم
مرتضى ولاطفاء الصدقيه على كلامه استشهد
بكلام احمد موسى والله
في امريكا بصراحه مستشفى على اعلى اعلى
مستوى يعني لما احمد موسى الواد احمد ده
لما بيقول الكلام ده الوزير
لا انا شفت بنفسي اتهمت مواقع مصريه
المذيع احمد موسى بتدوير لعبه قمار على
الهواء وفي رمضان برعايه وزاره التضامن
الاجتماعي وتقوم على الاجابه على سؤال
باتصالات هاتفيه مدفوعه
ومتكرره للدخول على سحب اليانصيب في ليله
القدر المباركه طب ايه المطلوب حاجه واحده
على
حضرتك في سؤال حضرتك او حضرتك بتجاوب على
السؤال مره عشرين مره زي ما انت عايز بعت
اكتر كلما تحدثت اكتر اتكلمت اكتر تزيد
فرص الفوز بهذه الجائزه الاكبر
صحفيه الجزيره وايقونه الحريه شيرين ابو
عاقله صارت رمزا عالميا للدفاع عن الحقيقه
حتى الموت كرمت في شرق الارض وغربها من
وطنها العربي الكبير الى واشنطن وامريكا
الجنوبيه واوروبا والهيئات المدنيه حول
العالم في ايلول الماضي كرم وزير الثقافه
اللبناني القاضي محمد وسام المرتضى شيرين
من خلال تسميه ركن باسمها في مكتبه بيروت
الوطنيه قيادي في تيار الرئيس الجنرال
ميشيل عون يدعى ناجي حايك
انا قضيتي هي لبنان قضيتي مش القضيه
الفلسطينيه ولا مش قضيه اليمن رد وزير
الثقافه المرتضى على حايك دون تسميته
موضحا ان تخصيص زاويه لشيرين امر قررناه
ونفذناه انطلاقا من انتماء انساني وقومي
واخلاقي فاذا امتعض الجاهلون يضيف المرتضى
لان الشهيده ليست لبنانيه الهويه فاننا
نسالهم وهل احترمتم قبلها شهاده
اللبنانيين الذين قاوموا الاحتلال
والارهاب وحرروا الوطن منهما اشاره الى ان
ناجحه قد حضرت الكويت دخوله اراضيها بسبب
كلام عنصري تعرض فيه للكويتيين
وللخليجيين عموما بحسب ترجيح الصحافه
اللبنانيه عنصري جدا
بنظر غيرك فخور كيف فخور
ختاما طرح طالب التاريخ في جامعه عربيه
سؤالا على استاذه لماذا الدول التي
احتلتها فرنسا تحديدا دون غيرها وتوجد
فيها تعدديه دينيه تعاني من ابشع انواع
الطائفيه فاجابه الاستاذ لان الاحتلالات
عموما والفرنسية منها خصوصا كان يزرع بذور
الفتنه الطائفيه والعنصريه والعرقيه
والتخلف والتبعيه الثقافيه المغمضه قبل
رحيلها عن البلاد كي يبقى قادرا على
تحريكها عن بعد من خلال اللعب على
التناقضات
هذه الدول التوسعيه نشرت العلمانيه
والليبراليه في مجتمعاتها لكف يد الكنيسه
وتحجيم الاكليروس فيما تعاملت بشكل اساسي
في محتلاتها مع ملوك الطوائف
وعمائمها من مسلمين ومسيحيين ومن كل مذهب
ودين الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
المستقبل
اهرب المسارات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]